comment trouver 12 milliards d'euros
d'ici à 2027 c'est la question à
laquelle les partenaires sociaux doivent
répondre d'ici fin avril il se retrouve
à 15 heures tout à l'heure au conseil
économique social et environnemental
pour le lancement de la conférence de
financement voulu par la cfdt
le but est d'identifier des pistes pour
redresser les comptes
il ya quelques semaines edouard philippe
a suspendu la mesure de l'âge pivot ou
hd qui libre à 64 ans mais il a prévenu
si les partenaires sociaux ne trouve pas
de compromis le gouvernement reprendra
la main le gouvernement pointé du doigt
par l'opposition elle lui reproche un
calendrier express dans l'examen du
projet de loi
écoutez la réponse du premier ministre
je n'ai pas peur du débat parlementaire
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat ce
qu'ils disent ce qu'ils disent que ce
débat devrait prendre la forme d'un
champ de braise ne disent pas quelque
chose auquel je crois
nous allons tenir le calendrier que nous
nous sommes fixés monsieur le président
marseille et le calendrier que nous
avons fixée c'est effectivement la
présentation d'un projet de loi en
conseil des ministres c'était vendredi
dernier et l'examen par l'assemblée
nationale puis par le sénat au cours du
premier semestre de ce texte de façon à
ce que nous puissions espérer
je ne veux pas préjuger de l'issue du
débat parlementaire mais c'est en tout
cas l'objectif que nous nous fixons une
adoption du texte avant l'interruption
estivale une prochaine journée
interprofessionnelle d'action et de
grève se déroulera le 6 février prochain
il hier huitième journée de mobilisation
nationale contre la réforme des
retraites sont 8000 personnes ont défilé
dans toute la france selon le ministère
de l'intérieur
un chiffre nettement inférieur à ceux
des précédentes journées
interprofessionnelles rassemblement
plutôt calme à paris avec 13
interpellations
et je vous propose d'écouter ces
manifestants toujours aussi déterminé
ça nous concerne directement parce que
si la réforme passe demain en fait c'est
nos cotisations qui n'ont pas augmenté
mais doublé et qui vont simplement faire
mourir d'un cabinet des cabinets comme
les nôtres mais donc sa composante 50%
des gens qui exercent ce métier on pense
dans cette réforme à toute la fonction
publique c'est aussi pour ça qu'on est
là aujourd'hui
la disparition du statut d'actif c'est
une catastrophe pour ce qu'il possédait
déjà
c'est aussi une mauvaise nouvelle pour
nous qui le demande y ont déjà depuis
dix ans c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour
les collègues de la fonction
hospitalière pour les égoutiers on suit
l'actualité des autres ensuite
d'actualité des avocats on comprend leur
système de retraite ont fait l'effort de
comprendre des autres professions parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui joue c'est
l'avenir de tout le monde accepté de
diviser les personnels accepter que la
retraite du privé du public baisse a
accepté de mettre à mal la sécu dans ce
pays la sécurité sociale sutsas a qui
vont s'attaquer ensuite non cette
réforme elle est mauvaise elle casse des
acquis qu'on a obtenu plus des années le
système il fonctionne on veut bien
rediscuter du système pour l'améliorer
mais on veut surtout pas ce set 4
organisé qui va forcément vous tirer
tout lé votre et vers le bas on est là
pour faire valoriser nos droits à la
retraite
à savoir qu'un négligé pour faire sa mue
il a 58 ans est l'espérance de vie y est
actuellement il part à 52 ans justement
profiter un petit coup d'arrêt avec la
modification des catégories actives la
prochaine conclure prochain âge à la
retraite 62
on retourne à mes fils sera la fille de
10 ans c'est pour ça qu'ils écoutent ces
termes en soient ici pour faire valoir
un droit mais se faire entendre contre
la faim de recettes